ja willkommen zu einer weiteren sendung
zur frage wie man philosophische
hausarbeiten schreibt ich wurde gebeten
noch ein bisschen konkreter anzugeben
worauf es eigentlich ankommt wenn man
sich ein interessantes thema vor setzt
eine interessante philosophisch
ergiebige leitfrage sich überlegt dazu
möchte ich jetzt im folgenden wieder ein
paar beispiele geben
wie schon im letzten video sagte nicht
jedes interessante thema ist für eine
philosophische hausarbeit gleichermaßen
geeignet viele themen erscheinen uns auf
den ersten blick als spannend und auch
als philosophisch ergiebig sind es aber
bei genauerem hinsehen im verlauf der
arbeit der ausarbeitung eben gerade
nicht das kann ganz verschiedene gründe
haben es kann ein zweites thema sein die
frage selbst kann falsch gestellt sein
oder und klargestellt sein also die
frage selbst kann dazu führen dass sie
nicht beantworten kann werden kann weil
sie zu viele voraussetzungen impliziert
die unmöglich im rahmen einer hausarbeit
alle angemessen behandelt werden können
und jetzt möchte ich mal einfach so ein
paar beispiele bringen die man sich
überlegen könnte für hausarbeiten
nehmen wir mal das beispiel künstliche
intelligenz das ist ein spannendes thema
ohne frage es ist ein aktuelles thema
und es ist ein thema zudem
philosophinnen und philosophen durchaus
auch etwas sagen können ja sogar müssen
weil es ein dringliches thema ist was
uns alle in der heutigen welt und auch
in der zukunft mit sicherheit immer mehr
beschäftigen wird
jetzt kann man sich fragen wie dieses
thema künstliche intelligenz
philosophisch möglichst angemessen eine
hausarbeit behandelt werden kann und
dieses thema halte ich für besonders
interessant weil es sich dazu auch viele
themen auf drängen die nicht geeignet
jetzt nehmen wir mal ein paar mögliche
fragestellungen zum thema künstliche
intelligenz die erste mögliche
fragestellungen wäre die man sich
stellen könnte werden wir irgendwann von
künstliche intelligenz beherrscht werden
diese frage hat sich sicherlich jeder
der jeder schon mal gestellt sie ist
eine problematik das macht uns angst die
künste intelligenz also hier können ganz
große probleme mit sich geführt werden
eine weitere frage ist die die damit
auch im zusammenhängt wir werden
irgendwann alle menschen cyborg zahlen
also cyborg ist eine mischung ist ein
organisches wesen als der mensch als
organische entität die mit künstlichen
versatzstücken stücken ausgestattet und
noch verbessert wird aber jetzt gibt so
eine frage inwiefern ist künstliche
intelligenz intelligent und schließlich
habe ich noch eine frage grenzen oder
thema grenzen und möglichkeiten
künstliche intelligenz so jetzt kann man
sich fragen welche dieser vier fragen
sind am besten geeignet um in einer
philosophischen hause bald von zehn bis
zwanzig seiten gut behandelt werden zu
können
und ich habe eine ganz klare auffassung
dazu ich halte die ersten beiden fragen
also die nach der beherrschung der
menschen durch künstlich ins und die
nach der frage ob irgendwann alle
menschen cyborgs sein wird für
ungeeignet das war sehr schlecht
geeignet um im rahmen einer
philosophischen hausarbeit oder auch
arbeit grundsätzlich behandelt werden zu
können und die anderen beiden fragen
oder themen halte ich für sehr gut
geeignet warum halte ich die ersten
beiden fragen nicht für gut geeignet und
zwar deswegen weil sie bestimmte dinge
voraussetzen die sie gar nicht selbst
auf basis der frage beantworten wollen
also der ersten frage wird künstliche
intelligenz bereit
vorausgesetzt als klarer begriff hier
kommt da noch viele weitere
problematiken ins spiel nämlich
beherrschung die bloße möglichkeit einer
beherrschen
also wir sind hier nicht mehr direkt
philosophischen bereich wir betreten
hier bereiche der soziologie wir
betreten hier bereiche noch vage der
zukunft spekulation und das ist
problematisch weil es nicht mehr streng
argumentativ sind häufig spekulativ nur
noch behandelt werden kann und hier
verlassen wir philosophin und
philosophen unsere kompetenz bereich
genauso die zweite frage
das setzt voraus sich mal ganz klar den
begriff des cyborgs er es bewusst zu
werden und es hat auch wieder so den
charakter einer zukunfts spekulation und
man erkennt nicht direkt eine wirklich
philosophische fragestellung
mann müsst die falken formulieren
vielleicht was ist ein cyborg und wie
ich anthropologischen implikationen
gehen damit einher
ja also wird der mensch zum übermenschen
hat das wäre eine interessante frage
aber die frage ob irgendwann alle
menschen cyborg sein werden die ist viel
zu vage
also die zukunft spekulation und das
sollten wir ganz klar von
philosophischen argumentation
unterscheiden
obwohl es ein sehr spannendes thema
natürlich ist so jetzt die dritte und
vierte frage die ich für geeignet halten
hier wird nämlich in der dritten frage
künstliche intelligenz problematisiert
hier wird nachgefragt was überhaupt das
intelligente an der künstlichen
intelligenz ist heute genauso die vierte
frage die nach den bedingungen der
möglichkeiten hat das ist ja auch so ein
philosophischer terminus dieser
künstliche intelligenz frage also etwas
kritisch betrachtet jetzt gehen wir mal
auf diese dritte und vierte frage ein
bisschen genauer ein und
überlegen uns mal wie man so eine frage
philosophisch weiter analysieren könnte
sie sind auch die gliederung einer
hausarbeit angibt man könnte erst mal
den philosophischen begriff von
intelligenz oder von rationalität klären
dann könnte man verschiedene formeln
akte von menschlichen intelligenz
unterscheiden also dazu gehört zum
beispiel erkennen verstehen einsehen
erinnern begreifen usw
jetzt könnte man diese menschlichen akte
von intelligenz oder rationalität auf
mögliche akte von künstlicher
intelligenz beziehen und danach fragen
ob sich so was dort auch finden lässt
also es gibt verschiedene formen von
künstlicher intelligenz zum beispiel
rechenoperationen also additionen
subtraktion das macht ihre
taschenrechner algorithmen
mustererkennung da wird schon spannender
künstliche neuronale netzwerke die
learning und so weiter und so fort
wir sehen es wird immer komplexer immer
intelligenter ich habe jetzt ein begriff
der intelligenz fast selbstverständlich
verwendet das müssen wir als philosophen
und philosophen hinterfragen wir können
uns nämlich die frage stellen ob
künstliche intelligenz überhaupt
bedeutungen erfassen kann also ob der
computer an verstrichen weiß was er da
tut
ob er ein begriff von einem gegenstand
hat wenn er zum beispiel gewisse muster
erkennen so ob er wirklich die bedeutung
dieses musters erfasst oder ob es nur
ein abgleich verschiedene vorgaben und
mögliche passender fälle ist genauso
kritisch sollte man der frage wie man
überhaupt über die operation weise von
künstlichen geräten spricht tut der
computer wirklich was handelt ein
computer wirklich oder ist es nicht ein
antrieb home office muss lernt ein
computer wirklich oder speichert er
nicht nur dinge ab
wir sehen jeweils richtig spannend und
hier können wir als philosophin und
philosophen auch kritisch uns in dieser
sehr anthropomorphen redeweise die
künstliche intelligenz sehr fruchtbar
auseinandersetzen und haben auch in
aktuellen fragestellung was zu sagen und
zwar etwas was nicht einfach aus der
luft gegriffen ist was eine spekulation
anbelangt sondern was wirklich hand und
fuß hat weil es sich mit den grundzügen
der menschen rationalität befasst so
jetzt hoffe ich dass das einigermaßen
verständlich war ich mein vorheriges
wieder noch ein bisschen konkretisieren
konnte und ich wünsche allen
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern viel
erfolg bei ihren hausarbeiten